And the answer is that Y1
should be 3 and Y2 should be 0.
>From looking at the bound we see
that we want them both to be small.
And looking at the constraints
we see that the non negativity
implies that this one
will always be met.
So we can more or
less ignore that constraint.
An increase in Y2 here actually
enforces us to increase Y1 as well.
So it should be clear that Y2 is zero,
and from that it follows that Y1 is 3.
Now you might have used some reasoning
like that, or you could have recognized
that what you were doing here was
really solving another linear program.
I asked you to minimize
a linear function subject
to a set of linear constraints and
the non-negativity of the variables.
This, then, is the essence of duality.
In trying to obtain a tight
bound on one linear program,
we end up with another one.